hey welcome back to hey [ __ ] podcast we
are the [ __ ] and hey what's up still
working on it we're so yeah yeah that's
a far cry for my first intro where y'all
using like hey [ __ ] I'm making fun of
it but then also people that are looking
at us the first time and probably don't
know that we're making fun of it I
imagine somebody watching the very first
episode for the first time and be like
what's this and then just clicking right
off ya know it's a term of endearment
but when we see each other like hey
[ __ ] yeah like it's very masculine
Allah say hey [ __ ] no [ __ ] you want to
suck my dick oh yeah it works every time
yes yeah I got her we got some wine
going on this time I'm gonna I'm the
sober straight man for this okay please
you guys get away see another sip okay
this little sip my way my alcoholic ass
open this [ __ ] with a drill I'm not
kidding we were like a drill but no we
were like oh we don't have a wine key I
was like well we're gonna take the
smallest drill bit here to create an
entry hole point and then we're gonna
take the larger one to drill in and then
pull it out we get anything else I want
to say a huge thank you to door - for
sponsoring oh yeah hell yeah door - we
got some wine from door - door - yes yes
have you anyway today we are talking
about what deal-breakers which that
might be one of them yep reasons why we
dump if we broke up with somebody why
did we do it all so maybe you're out
there having recently been dumped and
you're wondering why didn't it work out
well we're gonna try to enlighten you a
little bit and this also will extend to
like why didn't that date turn into a
relationship things like that and oh I'm
gonna tell you guys my number one
deal-breaker
that got me downloaded to hell on reddit
got me sent an onslaught of hate
messages and I still [ __ ] left that
comment up because it is my number one
deal-breaker
oh you're
shallow if that's a deal-breaker for you
[ __ ] you that's it oh yes go in balling
says I like when you do it down I relied
tripled that I did hear this after I had
like negative like 140 karma on reddit I
was like do I delete that bad
yeah that's bad okay that's bad what is
it okay beause I'll show you mine if you
show me what is your number one
deal-breaker
I'll show you want me to show mine first
yeah I'll get into it like 30 MGD
cuz that's my number one deal-breaker
mine too yeah all these cheaters are
like boring boring I mean I feel like
cheating is an obvious one yeah like uh
like oh when he beats me it's like no
[ __ ] well cheating is not a deal-breaker
for all people because some guys are
couples
well I'm women are cooked well kind of
but then you also have to realize you
have to like understand that
relationship why the cheating even
occurred Yeah right so you're you're the
way you're saying cheating now it just
sounds like this person is just like
horny and just wants to [ __ ] other
people just behind the back like mean
that happens but yeah necessarily the
case all the time Oh question this is
gonna sound okay this is gonna sound
[ __ ] stupid to y'all maybe
well we're hey [ __ ] group I'm pretty
sure we're not gonna think it's stupid
alright there's no judgement here so say
somebody that you were with cheated on
you yeah today okay today in the mindset
real quick yeah so you just found out
they cheated on you and they've told you
directly yeah this isn't already so
happy but they told you this is a whole
separate would be so yeah because I
would be like oh pass for me different
strokes for different folks okay so my
question is would that be the end of the
relationship over there yeah but I do I
have Tyco right like right now I have
Tyco yeah that's right I love ya
yeah I cuz I don't know why I've thought
about this before I like really like my
man and I are tight we talk about
everything and like of course if I found
that out I would be [ __ ] livid no if
ands or buts
well I'm but you've been with him for a
year Yeah right how long have you known
him before then like [ __ ] year before
that just so only well I could see why
you would be like deuce I mean I know I
would be [ __ ] pissed but I would still
sit down and be like why did this happen
Oh like I want it I want to hear yeah
it's like why did this happen is
something going on that we need to talk
about is this a pattern like I like it's
not just you cheated and that's over but
yeah I really want to know yeah height
that shouldn't be that black-and-white
like oh this this happened and then all
these seven years or whatever is erased
like everything is gone and like it's
like no there's a bigger story yeah I
would want to know for closure purposes
why I'm still done ya know I want to
know like did I fall short do you do you
have something you need to work on like
are you bored like what like talk to me
because maybe there's a way that this
isn't a repeating pattern and we can fix
this like don't get me wrong I'm not a
cup but I'm a communicator and like
you're right there's a bigger story what
the [ __ ] does a cook mean I sound so oh
you like to watch your significant other
[ __ ] someone else oh so she's using it
like exaggerating yeah she's obviously
not gonna watch him girl but yeah
wait so you just went back on what you
said it's not a deal breaker because
you're gonna talk to them about it but
well that's what I said well I mean like
cheating is like look you have a okay
cheating is like a 20 percent survival
rate I mean because I mean like at the
end of the day I know how I am in
relationship sometimes and like
sometimes I need to do better I'm not
saying that you need to just go out
there and cheat so I need this girl and
it's like and she was having problems in
a relationship and she started cheating
and and I I didn't like that like for me
that's not a good friend code thing for
me like if you're cheating yeah I'm
gonna like stay back so she cheated once
and we didn't talk to her and be like
yeah that's wrong I I I heard her and I
was like all right I'm like yo that's
not really cool and then like she
cheated on him again and she's
her reasoning behind it list she was
like well I was drunk the first time so
if I'm gonna cheat on my boyfriend I may
as well remember oh yeah but I told her
I was like you're doing this because
you're unhappy in your relationship and
you're not able to communicate that yeah
you're miserable about all these things
but you haven't gotten the balls to tell
him like hey I'm not happy with their
sex life I'm not seeing you enough I
need to rectify this so instead you took
the easy way out and went and found
something in someone else temporarily
because why not just break up with
somebody if you want to [ __ ] someone
else you guys you're so immature you
can't communicate with your significant
other you don't need to be in a [ __ ]
relationship yeah yeah sometimes things
are more complicated though because I
don't know if it's necessarily
immaturity or it's like the situation's
could be complicated and they could be
very vastly different yeah well I think
I think for me with that specific
example I'm like that person's a [ __ ]
because she has zero remorse yeah and
nothing for it and grabbing it and like
she's specifically seeking like to [ __ ]
like random outside of her like instead
of it just being like oh I fell in love
with my office manager like over the
years and my husband I haven't seen him
because I'm always at work and like
different things could happen you know
dude this girl when she like showed me
the guy she cheated on the first thing
was out of her mouth was look at his
Instagram he's got 22 K oh oh okay
that's who she's she was fused like she
thought that was like big then he's just
writing about that yeah yeah oh oh yeah
yeah I ended up not being friends there
anymore because she was just trying to
use me to socially climb oh [ __ ] oh yeah
you know what there's friend
deal-breakers - yeah we should talk
about that - wait here's the thing
though is that I don't judge people that
would stay together after cheating it's
a deal-breaker for me but then there the
one time I did get cheated on and I
ended the relationship it was actually a
huge blessing because that was such a
shitty relationship and there were so
many things in there that would have
been a deal-breaker for other people but
for me my [ __ ] dumb ass like I still
stuck with him and like continue to get
abused because I was just like well it's
not cheating you know yeah yeah and so
like like there was crazy [ __ ] like have
you ever dated somebody that like kept
top a file of like topless photos
of all of their ex isn't anyone they've
ever slept with in a minute now oh no
find that and then you're like [ __ ] this
is weird
and then you just stay together with
them Wow yeah so that kind of [ __ ] like
there was a lot of [ __ ] like that going
on in this one relationship and then
when I found out they were cheating on
me and then they denied it I had to find
out like on my own I didn't saw the
pictures
he was like now that's not no no I think
this is art you didn't deny the the
topless photos he was like all throw it
away that's just like leftover from like
who I used to be and all this stuff and
like I was like man it's like a trophy
Katie civil everyone you [ __ ] Ribeiro's
yeah oh the girls were asleep it was
weird weird weird
oh yeah like red flags all over the
[ __ ] place and I was like but I like
him imagine your sleep like you wake up
in the middle of night and your guy is
just like holding the sheet up like jazz
or even no later I found a picture in
his phone of me sleeping with my with my
ballot and I have never taken a topless
photo not for anybody not for my own
husband not for ever and I'm very clear
hard on that rule and there was a photo
of me sleeping with my [ __ ] boob out
it was [ __ ] and disgusting on that no
you know I have a deal-breaker
Oh finally oh yeah I have a deal-breaker
and this is like a weird like neesh one
so y'all know how like there's some
dudes that like they just want like a
nude like there or like just you know
these guys are like let me see your face
and like let me see a body pic and then
sometimes they're like oh let me see a
little more they mean like a little ass
like titty imagine like being like into
a guy and then finding out that he wants
to see like full-on puss like spread I
thought that's what all guys want i sent
full-on post phone yeah like every time
my god i like videos oh my god y'all
yeah breaker for me well because Nicki I
don't do pictures yeah yeah I don't do
pictures so if you just get close to it
yeah I don't do pictures either so if
you want a video of me full-on like
finger blasting my [ __ ] this is not
gonna work
I know see that's why deal-breakers are
great because you find out your
preferences like there's someone in
there like Gio that's in Tibet and yeah
yeah yeah it's just like not for yeah
okay it's not it's not forever yeah do
it
no I didn't know what my vagina looked
like till I was straight up like 13 I
thought we were in health class and I
saw a diagram and I was like that's not
what I look like it's just like a crack
yeah then I looked at it with a mirror
look in a mirror it's just the crack
beautiful like a crack yeah it's a
beautiful like burger bun and no clue
it's all pretty and I'll shy like the
diagram was like that's not a [ __ ]
vagina and then you open it up it's like
a scene from alien it yeah oh my god I
have one that's crazy yeah I have like a
bunch of like very superficial
deal-breakers so so it starts from like
how much I like this guy and then it
goes from like I think it's like I want
to settle so I'm like okay well okay so
he's not very alpha okay cuz I like Yuri
I'll [ __ ] like dog you make excuses
yes I'm like okay well he's not very
alpha but he's very creative right and
then he's not that creative and I'm like
okay well at least he looks athletic
which I love athletic bodies I'm like
okay well maybe he doesn't look that
like a black man does he at least have
nice hands and they start looking at
hand I love good hand like let me find
some Jack yeah if he has like little
nails and [ __ ] I'm just like oh yeah I
don't like that he chewed to the back
quick I can't do that I loves ya yeah
that's that's like a big deal breaker or
clammy hands wait what do you mean like
they're like like wet Oh like crabby
hands like this is my strong hand yeah
like my should get superficial is [ __ ]
I'm glad you said that cause mine is
very stiff they're like reminds the
opposite it's gotta be like clammy hands
no like I can forgive pretty much
everything like her clammy hands
100% I know that we che the marker like
the markers that I want oh yeah yeah
they have to be funny as [ __ ] like they
really have to make me laugh like belly
laughs every time we talk he's not that
funny
I you know he's pretty funny but no hot
is the thing is that I traded it
Steve's actually pretty funny yeah he's
really he's really funny and he also
apperceptive like I like to have deep
[ __ ] intellectual conversations where
we like dive deep into like purpose and
the universe and all [ __ ] and like
Steve's really good at that and I I just
need that kind of stimulation and so I'm
not really stimulated visually I'm very
stimulated mentally and if they don't
have that I have been known to like try
to settle on that so quant the one time
I dated a hot guy like like this guy was
like sorry so bad wine shits on the
corner no I'm in the doghouse okay but
like no this dude he was like one time
the video was on mute like everyone
knows there's just oh God
no buy me like a traditional like I'm
just being an ass dude was like AG
wrecking God like he had like like you
know what Boop that movie Hercules of
the cartoon characters and they had like
drawing oh yeah this dude looked like
one of those cartoon characters okay he
was like just chiseled and he was like
tall and like tan he was like forget
nice ass hair I'm like I don't even
understand how yeah he knows about but
it was because it was actually the worst
sex I've ever had but it's always like
that that I settled on those things like
the important things like this dude was
the dullest personality ever he was kind
of sexist like he would say like sexist
comments all the time and I would like
forgive it and like he was very dumb
like we could not have intellectual
conversations at all he also interrupted
me a lot which is like my biggest pet
peeve I [ __ ] hate being interrupted
like when we're having a nice
conversation and he was just drone on
about work for like an hour and not even
give a [ __ ] if I had to say anything or
not like I was just meant to sit there
and be
quiet I guess and I forgave a lot of
that and we dated for because he was hot
for five months I was 17 and I was very
hot and that was the only time that was
like the first ever time that I dated
like an actually like model looking dude
and a second time yeah that was the
first time out of two when I married the
second time there's no saving it yeah
what was that thing about Steve yeah is
that your same time do all right so yeah
that's a deal-breaker is having a Doulos
personality because I couldn't make it
last no matter how Oh usually you know
actually that were a really bad one for
me that I didn't realize until recently
is I will not date a guy that can cook
that Candace bit can cook NRC int you
not because I can cook and I don't want
to compete with him and I also I want
him to be helpless you know that's been
part of my mechanism to like latching on
so you can cook oh yeah I go damn very
well and like that's my thing I'm like
yeah baby what you want I'll make you
whatever you want and like if he can
cook he's like I know I can make it
yourself no I need him to be so helpless
he can't even feed himself I need to be
needed I need to be you mommy
no no but I like to cook and like I
don't I really like I really do not like
when a dude like cooks like I gotta say
that's me I got the one that got
downloaded cuz that's some yeah without
it oh my god after like after a while
you got to listen longer before Bose
reveals what this vote is yeah so let's
talk about like specific breakups times
you broke up with people what were like
what was the reason why I don't have a
specific breakup but I have specific we
dated and it never went to the next
level okay yeah yeah I had this one guy
who was like head over heels for me
right he would like give me random cards
and then he would like his dad was a
jeweler so he would like give me jewelry
Wow
yeah like he would surprise me and I was
um I think I was like 20 or 21 at this
time and like at that time you'd say it
feels good right you're just like oh
damn he's got
not that I really cared about that but I
was like oh security yeah yeah and then
like he was always just bending over
backwards for me and trying to just do a
bunch of [ __ ] for me but like for some
reason I just I just couldn't be
attracted to him like we never hooked up
but I was just like why don't I like
this click on paper it was good but then
there was no chemist no I think he was
too thirsty and I think he was like it
was it was too easy for me to like get
with him you know I mean like I just
felt like there was no work that needed
to be done and like I just felt like he
was giving me everything too quickly and
I'm just like this is weird like I don't
like like I don't like like he felt too
soft like I felt like because I have
such a dominant person yeah yeah I felt
like dude I'm gonna [ __ ] make you my
[ __ ] no I feel you because like one of
the things I like the most about Steve
is that we like banter a lot like we
like we like to argue with each other
because it's like it's hot I don't know
it turns me on like when someone doesn't
just agree with every [ __ ] thing I
say you know and like and then they have
valid reasons like why they disagree I
love that yeah and then they're right
and you're just like oh [ __ ] yeah I love
learning [ __ ] like I love like expanding
my [ __ ] mind
open my mind for you not before I open
my legs meanwhile my boyfriend likes to
play devil's advocate all the time and
it pisses me off it pisses me off so
much like they got to the point where
like the other day he said something and
like we were just driving I was like
quiet for a minute and I was like I hate
that [ __ ] like I don't I don't I don't
like to argue because I don't like to
make people feel bad I just want I like
I want us to be on the same page I want
to agree with everything and like I will
I never argue I like I can help convince
somebody on my side because there's a
reason why I've picked my side mmm
there's a reason and you need to come to
the light oh so you're like you won't
ever bend towards their light I think
there's something to learn from everyone
but basically no you all been
real deal I think there's something
about compromise most I think you just
want sex slaves dude no I'd I could
picture you having your bedroom with a
bunch of like little teddy bears right
first day about to hook up with the guy
she goes alright you ready
and then she has this button the Bears
[ __ ] fire around [ __ ] like chains
and [ __ ] you're like alright [ __ ]
you're mine she's like slap me ya know I
slept that know and like but you know
I've I have a very very like dominant
sexual side but I'm in a more like tame
relationship that's like normal very
passionate and so like it you know you
always like them to agree with you
yeah um no I playing devil's advocate on
some [ __ ] that the devil doesn't need
advocating he's he's he's he like works
in science and like does logic in
mathematics a lot so he luck always has
to see the other side and I'm like no
just look right here I've already chosen
ours and we will travel this road I
don't want you looking over there but
what about that way look I don't have
time for that [ __ ] down like me an
example I don't know what this means
give me an example I can't think of an
example but like with things I think I
think three steps ahead of anything I do
like you know like even in like my
career it's okay what if he says
something like this you're like hey
we're gonna do this all female podcast
and I think this is a really good look
he's like a devil's advocate well I mean
you just started this new job like did
you really like consider the time
commitment and like would he say [ __ ]
like that oh yeah absolutely like you
know like is this yeah but like actually
maybe I'm not as resolute as I'm
thinking because like I'll listen yeah
maybe you think maybe hold on like erase
the last 10 minutes yeah I did I think
so I don't know actually you know I
think you know I think that I've changed
a lot in the past year and a year ago I
was more this is where we're [ __ ]
going and actually now I listen a lot
more now you put a no wait
welcome back we're first we listen to
this a break alright y'all knock knock
it's uh who's there
hey [ __ ] giving you five dollars off
your next order from door -
did any other delivery service right
here right now I can give you a meal for
$10 straight to your door straight to
your office
think of your your favorite dish that
you want to eat right now pasta right
bacon wrong about I'm on a diet so mad I
said Fried Chicken first imagine it
delivered straight to your door right
now our listeners can get five dollars
off their first order of $15 or more
when you download the door - app and
into the promo code 40-50 c8y dude you
meet me down at the door - app and use
code b tch five dollars off your first
order of $15 or more yeah so that's five
off your first order when you download
the door - app from the App Store and
enter promo code c h again that's promo
code b tch for five dollars off your
first order from door - the first time
you know and we're back Bo's what were
you saying
alright let me just tell you about the
thing let me just tell you about the
thing okay are these this is a combo I
mean I I believe this is superficial I
think it comes from a weird place and I
think you know whatever I my biggest
deal breaker of all time is I can't
stand when a guy crosses his legs yes
yes I can't do it an effeminate
I can't do it I can't do it I can't do
it either
I there was a guy that we had been
talking for six months it's six months
and we had been we've been flirting for
like three years and like he moved
closer to me and I was like this is like
you know we're about to whatever and in
the same night he told he told me he was
like I love to take bubble baths and he
and I and then I was kind of like okay
that's fine that's relaxing but I was
like I was kinda like oh and then when I
looked over at the knees legs crossed
and he's like 6 6 - and so it just I
towards Justin crosses yes he I did the
white cross
it is uh don't worry George Steve does
the same thing it's good I think all
guys do it I think I think I've seen
Steve crosses like before anyway if I
see it and like I won't judge a guy like
if he's like a friend that's doing it
but like if I'm sir dating me attracted
to ya it it just it sends very like
perminov signals into my brain of his
ass it's done are you Anna same way I
mean look who the [ __ ] I'm married to
like I'm married to a [ __ ] Ranelagh
bar took a mattress that yeah like I
just like what made you like what you
like yes yeah I get it like if they're
like a little bit more on the feminine
side of the spectrum then you're like no
yeah I can it might it might be a
comfort thing but like in like you know
and I posted it on reddit I didn't say
like I hate this this is gross I posted
it from a standpoint we're like some
people are like why is this a deal
breaker this is so superficial and I
said hey
as a woman here that is afflicted by you
know psychologically not being able to
be attracted to guys it cross their legs
here's why like it comes from a very
like primitive standpoint of like I
think this is this is as a child I was
shown this is what's feminine this is
what's masculine yeah and that's still
ingrained in me I don't think it's right
but it's it's there and like I mean it's
what made sense to you yeah and so like
for me it's still really like baked in
there and like God and I would be so
bummed if a guy I like cross his legs
cause like ah I gotta go okay would you
have a conversation at least with him
first like hey can you not find Shaw so
you could say never do that again and
then be okay with it like it's hot one
and done I don't even know because I'm
not gonna offend them for something that
they're doing for comfort for example
okay I'll give you another
so Bart likes to do a lot of like baby
talk right like we invented like CUNY
right yeah see we liked like it's like
we we change ours into W so they're like
oh you're so cute when you I love you
right they will do baby talk I mean it
work no B it works we do something
similar okay but now when we're having
sex and he's doing that my guys that
during sex like it's a good year yeah
can I put it in your bowl
not like that but no no you want his
pop-up in your [ __ ] I wish she said it
like that because it's like so dirty
anyway uh but I had to talk to him about
that I'm like baby like you can't do
that like it's very confusing like yeah
like a little baby and I don't wanna
[ __ ] a baby I know but if he did that in
the beginning yeah it would I mean I
wouldn't I would talk to them for yeah I
said I'm like it takes me it takes so
long for me to like want to move the
relationship to the next step so I'm
like [ __ ] I already worked so hard I
don't want to lose it but yeah I'd like
for you you're like I'm out yeah I'm
sure it's just something turns off I'm
like hello friend it goes straight there
and like I but you know what to be fair
I think like besides that and cooking
like those are like my only like
real-deal bear you have the weirdest
[ __ ] deal-breakers there's a weird
one yours Jess yeah shoot right now I
don't really have a lot yeah I think um
I just have to get along with the person
who's like I don't have specific thing I
can't I'm trying to think of something
specific broken up with someone like Joe
has bad breath halitosis yeah that's
pretty that's pretty bad if it's like
like legitimately the most disgusting
[ __ ] and like you have you broken up
with something I broken up with all of
my boyfriend's I think okay so why did
you bring over that they weren't for
like quote-unquote deal-breaker things I
guess they're just more like sad [ __ ]
stories like it just went down the drain
for different reasons it's not like oh
this is a blanket like you're breaking
up is a good one maybe dating why didn't
they didn't go into a relationship oh I
think just it's all chemistry for me
like I feel like I can deal with a lot
of [ __ ] like marry Harry okay maybe
like if he was a bear in a past life
yeah kind of Harry
yeah shorter than you does that robin
williams r.i.p i love you so much oh
like that okay yeah that's kind of nice
a deal-breaker I guess so do it like
stupid short like way shorter than me
yeah
like five inches five four okay y'all
are pulling some [ __ ] out okay I guess
that works too yeah yeah I just don't
even think about it those because I'm
like up teeth
Joe has [ __ ] up see no he does it
that's a split tongue deal-breaker I was
just thinking a weird arm but it would
make you look like a [ __ ] I was the
other mutation maybe one that was like
optional oh my god okay well we're
talking about in a normal realm okay so
like if we go crazy then yeah I'm not
gonna date an alien or whatever would a
woman a Tucson did oh no I'm I think I'm
so straight that I that I don't even
like lesbian porn I like gay porn with
the gay men oh yeah I don't you just
want any extra dicks all day yeah
oh my the first point I watched I could
only watch gay porn because okay I think
I'm a gay guy so funny I feel like so
far with every episode there's two
people that are similar to each other
and like - like like Gio and I are on
the same page about a lot of stuff and
you I can't not anymore but like when I
first started before I lost my virginity
the thought of a dick going into my
vagina scared the [ __ ] out of me because
that seemed like I couldn't even like
put a tampon up there it was just too
tight and it was just so much and like
shakey doubles down and she's like my
[ __ ] is so tight - 28 well Steve and I
have had sex it's like losing my
virginity again it's just yeah so the
thought of a dick going in there like my
hymen breaks every grows overnight
basically yeah like you know what good
for you I mean regenerates yeah so yeah
the thought of a penis going in there
like freaked me out so I had to watch
only like guys doing it because then it
didn't feel like oh it's going in my
vision so you were watching him do it in
a tighter hole yeah it wasn't my yeah
yeah for me it's not about that but yeah
yeah okay you like you just like it I
just like I don't know I feel like it's
the it's guys being as like dirty as
they can be or even like watching guys
masturbate oh like they're like being as
gross yeah
I guess merit like it's a it's
embarrassed of and I kind of just like
how vulnerable they are jessica is the
greatest woman in America she was like I
like to watch guys [ __ ] each other and
jerk but like not effeminate gay guys
but like straight passing gay guys like
looking well not the ones that are so
built that they're like too wide and
they look gross okay she's got a very
specific gay guy that's like Metro very
nice straight passing handsome this is
like so different than interesting yeah
more questions
case study yeah whole video on that
later because for deal-breakers lesbians
yeah because like Joe vagina you don't
you and you're like what about the right
time what about someone that's not funny
yeah I think humor is a big deal so that
would be a deal like if he's just like
serious all the [ __ ] time so I guess
I [ __ ] up when I said I had no
deal-breaker enough people that had
breakers I guess so I guess I just
either like I veered towards them or I
don't and then so like all the people
that have deal breakers they're just
like blank from a distance
I don't think about blob I don't realize
that I have all these little things but
obviously now we've thought about a guy
that embarrasses you in public
Oh Joe Joe does all the time so
embarrassed like you're okay me and Joe
have a lot of deal-breakers but we're
still together I had one where when I
was in like my dating stages where I was
dating guys I had I was eating this one
guy like we went on a couple dates and
we actually had sex before we ever went
on a date so it was kind of backwards
that way and but I knew our chemistry
was good because of that so like I liked
the sex so I let him take me out to
dinner after the sex then I found out it
was is honestly it's like the opposite
of most stories because yeah the sex was
great we started with that then came to
dinner and I couldn't handle the dinner
stuff because
at dinner he needed me to be 100%
focused on him at all times and if I
like like spaced out to think about
something cuz I'm kind of a visual
person right so if you bring up a
concept to me and we're talking about
something I have to visualize it and
then I think about it and then I comment
on like what I think about right and so
he would bring up we'd be talking about
let's say outer space and I would like
think of something we were just talking
about and I would like my mind would
kind of like wonder like imagination
happens creativity happens and while I'm
thinking about that he's like yeah he's
like what are you thinking about
oh you have his fingers yeah he would
actually he would he's like Hello we're
having a conversation what are you
thinking about like I'm thinking about
what we were just talking about [ __ ]
but like basically he thought that I was
thinking about other dudes those
insecurities because I guess later he
told me it was because he's he was like
a good 8 to 10 years older than me
and he thought that because I was so
young that I was just seeing him as an
old guy and I was just like thinking of
other dudes and I was like do it's just
like your insecurity is what killed it
no Nicky it's also those you're too hot
like Bose no I'm serious like you can't
you stop I'm just saying he's looking at
you across the table and he's like she's
thinking about other guys that's my way
she's like oh my god like that was like
the farthest thing that I was thinking
about yeah 100 wasn't thinking about our
conversation but just like visualizing
and then thinking about sketches because
like we were both stand-up comedians and
so that's how I met him I booked him on
a show that I was doing and then he was
really funny and so we like hung out
more the funny really gets me and so
we're both clean comedy and I'm thinking
about like funny things like off of what
we're talking about and then I'm about
to share them and he's like what he's
thinking about like other dudes like he
yeah by the end of a he was like I just
think you're thinking about like I don't
know the last guy that you were with and
I was like what how to lose a girl in
5mon yeah yeah and
and he would also send me selfies which
was I don't know that's when I was it
was weird to me anyone unless I ask ya
right and it would be like not like dick
pic selfies like just selfies of him
like so insecure outside world I was
gonna give a worse date a bad date story
but piggybacking off of the why didn't
it happen I have the literal [ __ ]
worst one of all time yeah I think I
think I've told it on JK before but like
so I I met this guy on tender and he's
like super hot like 36 34 he's like an
executive for like a really big company
that a lot of people like another name
and I'm like oh and he like takes me out
on our first date like pays for
everything super nice I loved his like
his league demeanor and he's a super hot
like white guy with like blue eyes great
hair well-groomed and nice like trimmed
beard and like he's like 6 feet tall
well-dressed I'm just like you know and
then like I remember we went on our
second date and he started speaking
Spanish fluently to like the bartender
and I'm like what the [ __ ] like that was
attractive you know and I'm like game
for this but he loved to drink you know
and so like I think the third or fourth
time I went over to his house dude was
just he had like eight bottles of
mingling like around his bed and I'm
like word and he's like really wasted
and so we kind of like flutter like in
and out and then he moves into this new
apartment and he calls me and he's like
hey come over I'm like no no the next
day calls me again hey come over I want
to watch SNL with you and I'm like okay
I love us no you're high let's show you
know and so right after we got the phone
he texts me and he's like by the way my
ex-girlfriend wants to meet you and I'm
like yeah I was like that's funny
because I don't wanna meet her and he's
like okay okay okay cool cool cool when
are you gonna be here so I think that
that conversation is over I get to his
house he's got this brand-new apartment
in LA it's super gorgeous great view
very like modern and like you know it's
small so it's super contemporary and
like nice and it's got like a bar like
inside of the kitchen right and so which
is obviously why his alcohol I got
picked it I get there
he's disheveled it looked like he had
been drooling on himself there's alcohol
there's a limp t liquor bottle there's
beer bottles everywhere and then there's
also because it's a new apartment
there's a leak in the bathroom that's
really bad and so it's a really nice
place and it just looks [ __ ] trash
and he's wasted on the couch he's a
conscious snow bit come on and like I go
into like wifey status and I'm like okay
let me start cleaning up so I start
cleaning up his apartment yeah I start
cleaning up all the beer bottles and I'm
like give me one second I was like let
me clean this [ __ ] up and then like well
like what we'll watch TV as I'm cleaning
I had the [ __ ] front door open and
like I look over and the most beautiful
girl I've ever seen like long black hair
that's all flipped out great like
eyelashes on she's dressed really cute
and she's got this little like white dog
she comes in and she's got like this
really cute like raspy voice and she's
like hey and I'm like hey and she's like
what's up and she just comes in and like
you know like starts like kind of
settling in and we're both [ __ ]
confused like she and I are both looking
at each other like hella confused and
he's just like hey hey ladies like and
we're like and she like looks at me and
she's like after like a few minutes of
awkwardness she's like do you wanna hear
some talk cuz like I'm a girl's girl
she's like let's do this and I'm like
yeah let's and then she was like okay
I'm gonna take your phone cuz I need to
get back into the building so she takes
his phone we get into the elevator and
then we get downstairs and immediately
she starts going through his phone and
I'm like okay so I'm Bose and she was
like I'm his girlfriend and I'm like oh
okay and then she starts going through
and she's like I can't believe this
shit's happening again and then she's
again and then looks through he had he
had a conversation with a girl named
like Katrina and through that text he
had just broken up with her that night
there's a [ __ ] third girl in his text
messages and this girl is like oh no she
was like do you want me to call you an
uber I was like yes please before yeah
she calls me an uber from his apartment
and I'm like thank you I [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out she's like I'm gonna go
upstairs and take care of this two weeks
later they were dating what wait why did
he say that she wanted to meet you I
think you like he just likes drama I
think he was just drunk in one at a
three
and then and I still have the text
messages from him I will literally give
them to y'all to put up in the YouTube
video where he's like where he texted me
at 4 a.m. and was like hey come back
she's gone now Oh
what are you doing and then like the
next day I was like sad face come on
just now and I'm like you were too hot
to be that like this is like this was
did you think about it though we like
man should I do dude I did know what
should I do what like go back oh yeah
hell no dude that guy's [ __ ] insane
absolutely insane
that [ __ ] was wild can't be doing that
when you're 34 she said as well I mean
if you're that hot you probably can't
I'll show you maybe that's all he had he
just has his hotness and he just thinks
like how much can I milk this I think
well I got it you know because like I
was like I was ugly I'm still kind of
ugly but like not as ugly and like when
you're growing up you have to get like
other redeeming qualities if you're
always hot you don't have to work on the
other [ __ ] yeah that's true yeah yeah
cuz that's why a lot of that cliche of
like the popular hot people getting all
fat and sloppy yeah dude that one guy
that I was talking about in the last
episode if you go back there was this
one guy that like we dated for two
months and he was like a popular guy and
he broke up with me and like most
harshest way like told me all laws like
he told me like I had too much hair on
my upper lip like a mustache and like I
got I [ __ ] aired forever after that I
mean told me I wasn't girly enough he
told me that I was just really awkward
and weird which that's true he told like
just a lot of things like I got into
makeup after that I got into like how do
I do hair how do I walk in heels like so
many things and back then we didn't have
YouTube so I had to like look all that
[ __ ] up and Marie Claire and
cosmopolitan it I was working my ass off
trying to be a female and yeah so that
guy though he is like became this like
coked out fact I wish how do you get fat
well I don't know but here's some facts
somehow ate a bunch of Subway sandwiches
after he's not okay
yeah but anyway I think because he was
you know pretty attractive and popular
during like his teen years like then you
just think that it's always gonna be
that way
just pull whatever [ __ ] you want and
then it doesn't happen anymore did any
of you guys peak in high school do you
feel like or were you popular in high
school gia were you popular oh yeah I
say I kind of was but there was also
times where I kind of wasn't so it
wasn't the haul of high school like I
was super popular but I feel like
sophomore junior year I was like killing
it yeah then senior year I just like
blacked out my entire life I came to
school and a completely opposite
different clothes and I and I just
showed up like with middle fingers and I
was like can't wait to get the [ __ ] out
of here [ __ ] all you fake [ __ ] that's
jazz I know I removed myself from it so
and now what happened junior year I
realized that senior was coming and then
the rest of life was gonna start I was
like I don't need any of these
[ __ ] these fake [ __ ] dance
you up your whole spot yeah I blew up
the whole [ __ ] spot Wow fake [ __ ]
we were talking about deal breakers with
friends though did you have that yeah
high school I think it's just fakeness I
don't know just yeah like in sincerity
all of that yeah I broke up with the
friend once like in college yeah it was
this really cool girl um at time in
college I wanted it like so in high
school I was a [ __ ] complete mess in
middle school I was doing really good i
had like 4.0 straight a's high school
rolls around i'm like oh [ __ ] let's
smoke weed so i focused on that and I
had like a 1.7 or something my god that
was really bad and then my senior year I
was like really into sports so it's the
only way to play sports is you have to
get I think have a minimum 2.0 or
something like that I forgot your
parents not murder you I just hit it and
they were just so busy so really matter
and then so come College like I'm really
focused now cuz I'm paying my own way
and then so I met another girl that was
just as focused and like about school so
I'm like dude she's Thai and she was
like really independent and really like
like pretty alpha someone oh that's
[ __ ] awesome I want to hang out with
her but she would get like really
jealous of me like hanging out with
people or like being in a different
group and she would like try to tell me
how to dress or how to talk and I'm like
this is [ __ ] weird and I'm like I
like I talked to her and I'm like hey
like I think you just have to change the
way you are like I don't like that like
you can't talk to me like that I'm like
not like
I don't know but I set it in a way where
she's like are you breaking up with me
yeah I was just like yeah I think I am
like you're really negative and you're
really pushy she's like okay and we just
broke up
whoa it was so weird it's actually
really mature yeah I was it's really
mature wait you know touching on that is
there is there anything for you guys
like the opposite of deal-breakers that
are like deal sealers like you said that
she was independent and like you know it
seemed really driven and so yeah like
that like is there like what do you guys
have a friend I have a ton of deal
loyalty yeah 100%
I am once I am locked in and I've
consider you a close friend which is
like that's like a very small circle I
like have your back for [ __ ] ever
like to the end of time if anyone ever
tries to talk to shoot it on you if
anyone tries to actually about any one
of you girls I would [ __ ] murder them
like not for real not physically but
like lyrically lyrically out all right
bars after bars about them but yeah no I
would like I would 100% friendships
because they just one of my like close
friends you know I've totally like
annihilated people like just goes to
their ugly annihilated them so if I'm
that loyal and then I find out that
those people are not as loyal to me
they're [ __ ] done like I just I don't
annihilate them I don't murder them I
don't get aggressive at all they just
disappear out of existence like I no
longer have them in my headspace yeah
they don't exist in my same realm I feel
like you can tell from a mile away
before you even get close with somebody
before they even have time to betray you
you can tell who's a loyal person yeah
like I don't know what surprised how
many people can't though really yeah how
do you tell I don't even know like I
there's you know there's something
there's something just very real and
very trustworthy about like some people
you know like when I talked to I talked
to David about this one time like
because David and I clicked pretty
quickly and there's this weird thing
with some people and I do it with like
y'all we're like when you guys say
something it doesn't pass through a
filter of well what do they mean what do
they actually mean what are they saying
like using be lit like you feel like
every word they say it's truthful there
are real
person and that you can detect their
loyalty by you know they're very honest
and so if they're hanging around you and
talking you like they're a friend like
you believe it like you buy it like
you're down whereas some people there's
a little bit of fakeness and you can
just feel it
yeah when there was like an agenda or
they're trying to get empathy or some
sort of thing because for me like it's
when people open up and they're
vulnerable
and they like you know share something
really like close to them and real that
they would just wouldn't share with
other people it's kind of like that's
how I know that that that like we're in
a closer friendship then like for me
it's not that yet it's not no because
I've come across a lot of people who
become very vulnerable and then they're
just very open but they're doing that
with everyone oh yeah I'm also really a
person to get close to but they'll do
that to everyone and I'm just like okay
that's just a type of person that you
are
but then what proves for me at least
where I'm like damn they're [ __ ] down
is when they're like the loyalty part of
it when I see them backing up other like
their friends or their people I like
that like they'll step in and they'll
like check me on something like like you
did that once I mean you didn't really
check me but I forgot what was happening
but you were like oh are you gonna tell
so-and-so and I'm like oh my god that's
so [ __ ] down of you and like things
like that like like they have like this
dope moral compass where I'm like yeah
I'm like I [ __ ] love substance II -
yeah being open consistently and not
just one time when you're drunk
yeah and then just consistency of
actions - like you know they're gonna
show up you know like everything because
some people are they're just fake to
your face and they say whatever they
think you want to hear but then like
they don't actually show up for you when
you need them like or just for anything
you know I think my number one is what
Gio said like I've always described it
as like having a good heart like
somebody that legitimately like has a
good heart but I think it's having a
good moral compass like if I can tell
somebody it's in it and I think that
also means like you know if I'm pointed
north and their moral compass is off so
north we're all on the same page we're
walking the same path and we're [ __ ]
hand-in-hand you know like we're synched
up and like I [ __ ] with that if I feel
like you're leaning a little too far
east we're not on the same page we're
not having the same conversation all the
time and like I want people that I
really connect with yeah yeah same with
like just dating like you can feel it
too like you can feel that they're just
trying to see
with you I leave my maybe I just feel it
but you get like an inkling yeah I like
questioning it yeah and it's just like
we do you want to get to know me or are
you just trying to like [ __ ] me right
now this is weird sometimes you just
want to be [ __ ] they're like cool
that's what I'm like hey just so you
know it's just about sex yeah I never
did that I've never had oh I used to not
a fat man I used to be just a
relationship person then when I was
going through the breakup it was like it
was the first time in my 20s that I was
single because I was very serial
monogamist so I went from like a five
year to a two-year relationship and so
those seven years of being in a
relationship but then I was finally
single and I was like okay I gotta just
like explore what dating is like like
while I can do that and because I was
still like not over my last relationship
I wasn't emotionally available to be in
a relationship with someone else but I
did want to have sex like I did still
have a sex drive and was horny and if it
went longer than six weeks I was like I
swear I'm [ __ ] the next person that
walks by me like you got to like a point
where I'm like aim I would rather have
sex with someone that I know like a
friend and be like okay you're out of
the friend zone let's go [ __ ] nothing at
that point do your turn-ons and
preferences or whatever did do those
take into account they do in the sense
that like you have to stay turning me on
like if you like for example that guy
that we had really good sex and then we
went to dinner
and he was like hello pay attention to
me I'm like oh I can't handle that now I
don't even want to have sex yeah oh
there was just one guy that we were
hooking up and the sex was pretty good
but I had said like just sex we don't
want to I don't want a relationship or
anything and he goes yeah but I know
it's gonna lead there because like
people say that but then they fall in
love with me and I was like oh you know
into yourself and then I didn't wanna
have sex with him anymore either what
the [ __ ] yeah are they you know no but
they were all like people that I was
friends with like they're guys that I
thought were kind of funny and then like
I got to know them a little bit better
like yeah couple yeah I'll do it but I
don't want anything more I just want
like you know I don't think I can [ __ ]
my friends they were like close friends
to begin with oh yeah it's like I feel
that like we hung out in groups before
we've like had text conversations before
about you
a tiny bit of security I have like it's
not I'm pretty sure they're not a
murderer but Rea it's still mysterious
enough to exactly like I don't know you
know yeah but like I know you're not
gonna hurt me you're sure a lot of
mutual friend that kind of thing yeah
yeah do you guys have any like telltale
signs like I feel like some guys would
be interested in hearing like what like
what is a big sign that a date is going
poorly like you're out with this guy
you're about an hour and a half in like
if you're not interested like what
mannerisms do you have oh if they're
just agreeing with like you said before
or they're just agreeing with everything
I'm saying that's boring as [ __ ] and I'm
oh you do two eyes you I just stopped
drinking
would you like another drink and I'm
like no that's that good clear sign yeah
you know and I'm not interested anymore
mine is uh dude if I open up reddit on
the date yeah on your phone but it
especially if I open up like a bored
IMAP or also another one of mine is the
laughs I never dated enough to know but
I think I think I feel like so I feel
bad if I'm ready on it so it takes a lot
for me to want to get on a date with
someone right yeah so like I think the
minimum is like three months of talking
to someone oh yeah yeah I'm [ __ ]
weird
so then after at that point if we're on
a date now then I'm just like I'll just
stick it out but the the shift happens
when I no longer give a [ __ ] about what
they want to do now it's like okay well
I'm gonna have fun yeah so oh you know
okay well I want to go roller skating or
I want to go let's just drive around and
listen to music because I don't want to
try yeah I've done that before too
I've absolutely it's so funny that we
all have like so far like really
distinct tells yeah but there I don't
know like do do you have something like
I think I try to just exit like oh no I
got a headache or something like I got
you do that to this to us all the time
yeah well actually do get migraines okay
excuse but yeah before I got yeah I'm so
sick exit right now yeah I'm trying to
exit
right now no I think it's just like I'll
come up with something you know I'm like
oh yeah we'll definitely stop drinking
yeah that's the first step and then it's
just like I would keep drinking No so I
reminded me of one thing I did go on a
date one time where I knew right off the
bat like the guy walked in and I was
like oh no no what's up yeah like he
just I could tell by the way he was
walking and I just it was just all off
everything was off and on this
particular guy I had met him randomly at
a bar like when I was out on a girls
night and he came drunkenly and and he
was like like on this like bark
pub-crawl thing and he was his hair was
disheveled and he was like in a t-shirt
and he was kind of funny and he was
really drunk but he was making me laugh
and I was like I'm not a girl's night
he's like what kind of lease to have
your number I was like I never do this
but [ __ ] fine and so I did and I
found I hated improv with people that I
knew so like it was kind of like neutral
stuff and then we wouldn't agreed to go
on a date and I was like I don't know
I've never done this before and when he
came in he was a complete 180 from that
guy he was like buttoned up [ __ ]
gingham shirt with a matching gingham
tie with de'longhi but it likes a picnic
picnic okay yeah picked again and then
like hair slicked like with like just
side part ready Freddy it breaks my
heart I know and he was like 10 years
older than me so I was 24 and he was
like
yeah and your little yeah yes I wanna
hug him
I know no but that was the thing is that
like I know I had met him and I mean
he's like is this what the young people
like to wear yeah seems like he seemed
like such a sweet guy but not like you
could tell right off that I was like
nope but I knew he has a triple-a card
and I knew I have a triple a card like
yeah a 9 to 5 person with I have a
triple-a card now like maybe if we might
he has a cost for yeah yeah he's like
the type of guy that would ask you
during sex do you like that would I
ended up becoming like friends with this
guy actually like the way later like
without him there like texted you in the
morning and said how did you sleep
beautiful breakfast he's actually such a
sweet guy and I feel bad he was saying
but I knew just from him walking in I
was like this is not gonna ever happen
and so I just got wasted like good
wasted it was around Christmas time too
and we were at this like sushi place and
I just ordered
I ordered a sake and they brought it out
cold and I was thinking was gonna be a
hot sake but they brought a cold sake
out and they had it on a bed of ice and
at this point I was like four vodka
shots in and I'm a lightweight like I
could drive off of two so I was like
[ __ ] gone and they brought out this
cold sake and this like crushed ice like
snow it was like snow powder you know I
was like whoa and they made snowball and
I [ __ ] through snowball fight like
it's a snowball fight I just think she's
so different yeah [ __ ] drunk and I
was like at this point cuz it's like
what you said like I'm just gonna do
what I want to do yeah cuz if you leave
I don't care right care where I'm not
gonna buy would you want to stay in the
day though I would just go the [ __ ] home
or go somewhere else because he was nice
and like fun but just I wasn't a savage
so you just feel bad so you're gonna put
a pill you think Nikki's like I'm
already
my makeups done let's yeah let's make
someone else to go somewhere okay Jess
but we went out to a bar after and we
played video games and we liked it did
darts and stuff and it was like a really
fun time just I was it just wasn't
leading to sex we're I just realized a
really huge [ __ ] deal breaker as
you're saying that you're describing
that guy for me if the person is a
[ __ ] tool it's an immediate order
yeah so it doesn't matter if they're
geeky or they're really passionate about
like an ant farm and [ __ ]
if they're confident about just who they
are as a person then I'm like that's
[ __ ] hot so I don't care if they're
like eat because I love athletic bodies
but if their puny is [ __ ] but they're
like rocking how puny they look I'm like
oh [ __ ] like some dancers like there's
some dancers and stuff like there
they're not athletic or they're not
necessarily attractive but they have so
much confidence I mean if they have like
a good face like it did me yeah so this
guy like his personality just not like
it wasn't there was no finesse
contraction yeah he was just like he was
fun but not like yeah there was no
connection but if they were a douchebag
like if they were just like I can't
stand like oh maybe that's why I bounce
it I was I was dating like a lot of
douchebags I think yeah so I would be
like I don't give a thug bow oh you and
you know what you probably attract a lot
of douchebag yeah cuz you're so you're
not playing hard-to-get like you're
really like I don't [ __ ] like you and
so like it's like a challenge and so the
douchiest guys they're like okay she's
blonde she's hot and she does I wasn't
mom doesn't want me you but maybe inside
I don't want for like three months of my
life yeah like that's probably oh you
know what actually wait are we good on
topics I've just been asking all
questions cuz I really want to know good
oh my I don't know what that means does
that mean time oh okay keep rolling yeah
oh okay so alternatively what is a good
sign that the date is going well because
I know what mine a [ __ ] I know it like
I can't just I can't stop thinking about
us making out yeah really yeah I mean
like what do you do my it my sign
is after the date if we go to the second
location oh yeah so my my boyfriend I
went on our first date we went and we
saw a movie we hung around we went to
the Grove and the bowling alley I saw
your story but like the first one we
went to a movie theater then we watch
around the Grove then it was like time
to go home and then while we were on the
car was like hey do you want to like go
grab drinks or get some babe you're
trying to extend it yeah I don't want it
to end yeah yeah yeah because you're
like I've gotta go I don't know if like
for that with that one guy we went to so
many different places and it was just
for fun that's why I was like yes I
wouldn't go to another place I did one
OKCupid date where I was like I just got
to try it and see what happens if you
date a complete stranger and this guy
was super effeminate like like
flamboyant effeminate where he was like
oh my god I can't like I eat when I'm
like on a date because this makes me
like so embarrassed in my way like that
I get on the date because he planned
this whole date and the things he
planned sounded really fun like we went
to this comedy show and it was like an
art battle comedy show and then we went
to a tapas bar with a hookah bar and at
the end of the night he gave me the
weirdest kiss he like no I told him the
story before he picked me like okay bye
anyone like that and then he left and
then I win the car and I was texting my
brother I was like I just want on a date
with the gayest dude he taps on the
window I roll it down and he grabs my
face and sticks his tongue down my
throat and he's like I couldn't leave
you with a grandma kiss oh it's so
confused meanwhile jess is like totally
okay with that like at this point I'm
asking like just dating a guy that took
a little effeminate and then she comes
out with a beer and she's like I want
you to [ __ ] him yeah that's the story
that's true I should have stayed in but
most of the guys I dated were so [ __ ]
douchey that it's not a funny story yeah
that's not a fun story it's just like he
was a cop and he was an [ __ ] you know
that does sound fun though he was a cop
yeah
save [ __ ] for another episode and if
you enjoyed this please give us a thumbs
up rate us if you're listening on itunes
all that stuff give us five stars it
really helps us out
this was hey [ __ ] and we have more hey
[ __ ] that are in our hey [ __ ] crew
and they will be on future episodes so
subscribe do all that stuff and just
wanted to think again door - [ __ ]
thank you for our door between our times
is like a Christmas sing to our door
yeah so thanks again - door - four or
five dollars off did you already say
that no okay five dollars off your first
order download door - now improve and
use promo code bth i'm say that again
because they came out so wrong puts for
five dollars off your first order
download door - now and use promo code
BTC go on get you a little snack good
bye [ __ ]
bye